[музыка]
е
потому что будут сложные участки
серпантийные горы и так далее на таких
участках Мы перед ними должны
остановиться и инструктора скажут кому
за руль сесть Мы завтра выдвигаемся на
Зыряновск приезжаем туда на месте
инструктаж на баги объяснение посадка и
до обеда едем до обеда едем
смотрим привыкаем и так далее первый
день у нас всегда это адаптация
[музыка]
виды шикарные такое ощущение что мы едем
не по Казахстану где-то в Швейцарии
очень красивые горы озера природа такая
Живописная как будто на другую планету
попали
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
нажимайте большую и заднюю кнопку вместе
И слушайте женщина внутри мы ее
маленькую
она должна сказать это японские БАДы я
сам с ними подписал недавно контракт вам
подарок от Marine
это просто нереально
[музыка]
супер вообще усталость как рукой снять и
температура Такая прям идеально
[музыка]
Кедровые орехи
заправленные
горчицей женской и с майонезом
[музыка]
бодрый веселые искупались сохнем
наслаждаемся
[музыка]
мы кайфуем
малину Собираю
конкурирую с медведем
первые затык
Но сейчас все будет налажено и продолжим
движение
это было нормально
мы когда вместе Мы команда когда мы
команды можем все
[музыка]
первый день
Осталось совсем немного
и мы у цели первой каких-то 30 км 30-35
Внизу стоим ждем дальше
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
жесткая грязь прям такая ребята Многие
говорят Первый раз почувствовали запах
полыни первый раз с детства так не
ныряли в грязи Блин вообще все
по-другому у всех отпустило многие
кто-то я начал другим подчиняться
говорят
а он сам большой руководитель и
Ну блин классно вообще сегодня было
вчера было классно
то что все соблюдать дисциплину опять
свой сайт
свойства любого рукой я всегда говорил
первое одно из первых свойств
руководителей умение подчиняться
потому что руководитель не рассматривает
подчинение и начальство как унижение
либо как человеческие качества он
рассматривает как систему он видит что
система должна работать а чтобы система
работала должен кто-то говорить более
компетенции а кто-то исполняет Поэтому
всегда может поменять кресло может быть
дополнительным тут же может стать
исполнителем не проблема Это для него не
западло Я раньше в армии удивлялся Так
что наши командир рассказывает там
пришёл командир работает и рассказывает
[музыка]
вот показал там это причем вообще не
париться я подумал Ну думал это военный
вообще на самом деле это свойство
руководитель это свойство руководителя
не получается рукава засучил сразу раз и
пошел сам делать показывать
Надеюсь все получится и будет еще лучше
чем вчера
все должно быть вовремя самое интересное
момент не пропускайте
а то вчера был Трэш полный еще песня Там
была
кажется не забудь поставить
[музыка]
мы сейчас заехали
дома нам нужно этот помыть машины
перегрелась Короче
этот и вода с электричеством решаем
вопрос
[музыка]
пытаемся спасти машину которая греется
хотим обмыть
радиатор
Надеемся будет все хорошо
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
всё поехали Первый пошел второй третий
четвертый пятый за мной поехали
[аплодисменты]
[музыка]
человек был только я видел Сколько
собрал 8 человек
Я хотел сказать что это самый лучший
[музыка]
У нас есть классный освежитель воздуха
вонючка
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
жизненные цели это то что люди достигают
за счет стимула Стимул этой острая палка
с остальным наконечником в Древней
Греции и тыкали в жопу Быка что может
тянуть плуг либо телегу отрицательный
только отрицательные Стимул Только
отрицает это палка которой тыкают от
которой бык убегает
так вот смотрите Стимул и за счет
символа это люди достигают жизненных
целей Что такое жизненных целей это
купить дом машину обеспечить семью
перевожу надо язык стимула он звучит так
избежать нищеты избежать голода пола что
тебе может драйвить только смысл когда
мне говорят про прокрастинацию или я
говорю прокрастинации лень это особый
механизм
созданный для того чтобы отсекать от
человека все действия не имеющие для
него смысла
думать прокрастинации лень это особый
психологический механизм который
отсекает все действия которые не имеют
для тебя смысла не проявляешь интереса к
жизни то жизнь тебя как потребитель
энергии просто из розетки выдергивает и
всё А каким способом
поэтому здесь очень важно поэтому
важно чтобы не включился механизм
саморазрушения а для этого ты должен все
время этому миру должен доказать что ты
нужен по всему миру что ты востребован и
у тебя все время должны быть
незавершенные дела незавершенные дела
Это миссия то есть не достигнутая цель
Потому что когда человек достигает цели
он радуется очень короткое время потому
что происходит всплеск гормонов но
гормоны долго на высоком уровне
держаться не могут они опускаются и у
человека происходит разочарование
пустота
[музыка]
но ощущение что я как Робинзон Крузо
здесь дикая природа очень красивая
Живописная местность Мы живем в
абсолютно полевых условиях то есть
умываемся на речке
палатках максимальная все такое
приближенное
к природе вроде ехали вчера
едем как будто с детства его знаю такие
эмоции взрыв эмоций Бах и вуз уехали и
водой грязная катилась такая
не должно быть не должно быть приятно Но
несмотря на это очень приятно
[музыка]
эти ожидаем Мы сейчас выезжаем на
бирельские курганы музей посмотрим потом
на озере Язево это Победы потом едем на
рахмановские ключи там купаемся потом
возвращаемся банька чайная церемония уже
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
узнали историю этого места как здесь все
происходило И сейчас уже приблизимся и
посмотрим это место царей как это все
было уже зная то что там происходило что
там нашли
[музыка]
такая природа
не знаю по-другому раскрывает запах леса
вот это все
мы вообще-то такого Кайфую от этой
прохлады
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
У нас есть в Череповце чертово колесо
так и я говорю мне вот не страшно Вот на
всех там Диснейленде кататься так не на
черном колесе страшно потому что я
смотрю Оно такое все в трещинах Я думаю
кто его варил а он готов сороковых
наверное
[смех]
[музыка]
мы разобрали его
что нас датчик скорости погнал перестал
показывать скорость расстояние и
перестал разгоняться
[музыка]
сегодня уже третий четвертый тире
четвёртый день города все восхищены у
всех хорошее настроение
[музыка]
вода системы
[аплодисменты]
[музыка]
река черный Иртыш Вот вы можете видеть
она вот так петляет петляет петляет
петляет петляет петляет и уходит туда
вон туда уходит и все что зеленое это
казахская сторона все что желтая пески
это китайская сторона
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
везение это благоприятное стечение
временных и пространственных
обстоятельств
нужное время в нужном месте Вот это
называется везение то есть от тебя это
никак не зависит это зависит только от
благоприятного стечения обстоятельств
[музыка]
ожидание были скромнее
Я просто супер Я здесь на самом деле это
какая-то
перезагрузка это что там тема
переосмысления это не
какие-то такие громкие слова
Я думаю Я это буду переваривать
определенное время и Возможно даже
некоторые вещи я даже уверен что
некоторые вещи я буду додумывать еще
долго здесь приходит понимание всего вот
если есть какие-то вопросы ты на них сам
себе отвечаешь
вот этим очень понравилось понравились
ребята формат То есть все люди но они
такие
радушные все
закрывать сезон будем
[музыка]
я уже хочу домой хочу нормальную кровать
хочу хорошо поспать безусловно Всем
рекомендую это тоже это очень интересно
это очень
экстремально это очень грязно это очень
романтично В общем все эмоции вся
палитра эмоций я испытал
[музыка]
вообще у меня это пятый тур и каждый раз
как первый раз потому что столько новых
эмоций новых идей знакомств хотел вообще
предложить и подарить этот тур своему
близкому человеку но не получилось так
как не было мест Свобода Я просто
удивлялся
только дело Теперь я понял там есть
такое один секрет я вам расскажу
Но это будет короче платная информация
ребята вот но тема крутая в общем я
максимально избегаю пользу из этой
поездки больше даже чем С предыдущей
маргулан Очень круто и развернуто
ответил на все наши вопросы дал много
подсказок Поэтому с точки зрения эмоций
скорее всего это ощущение полное
удовлетворенности и целостности одно из
лучших путешествий которые были за всю
мою жизнь поэтому здесь есть четко
выверенный какой-то баланс между экшеном
драйвом комьюнити нетворкингом и самое
что крутое но для меня конкретно это
знание мне повезло оказаться нужно на
месте в нужное время с нужными людьми
очень системный подход
показывающий Как как можно и как нужно
относиться к
работе к жизни
окружающим к семье
такой мастер от маргулана
[музыка]
по-моему оделись даже не помню
один из величайших туров когда без
перевёртышей
в течение вот этих 6 дней 7 дней просто
идет взрыв мозга столько инсайтов
столько каких-то идей мощных Поэтому я
думаю что
должен человек который хочет
масштабироваться и оптимизировать все
процессы
[музыка]
вот так завершается наш очередной
багитур А теперь